일단은 예전 모습을 보면은
이거였어요 이거
야 이거 진짜
엄청 오래된 주택이었습니다 저 예전에
살던 집 같은 저희 집 예전에
이랬거든요
[음악]
내년에서 빌 사람입니다 제가 오늘은
최근에 더글로리가 굉장히 좀
인기가 많잖아요 더글로리의 주인공
송혜교 님의
빌딩을 분석하도록 하겠습니다 그
송혜교님은 그 건물이 이제 한남더힐
앞에 있어요
용산구 내에서도 되게 거래가 잘 되는
곳에 있고요이 건물입니다
여기
한남더일 바로 앞에 그래서 여기
앞에가 좀 이렇게 한남더힐이 앞에
있다 보니까 유명한
맛집이라든지
고급스러운 업체들이 좀 많이 들어와
있어요요 건물입니다 자재는
롱부리를 쓴 거 같아요 일단 디자인이
그래도 신경을 많이 쓴 그런 설계인
거 같아요 그래서 여기 느낌을 보자면
지하 2층에 지상 5층 건물인데
건물을 보면은
요게 이제 다 공간들이 좀
다른 거 같아요 색다른 거 같아요
그래서
뭔가 하나
둘
셋
넷 다 그래서
요렇게 좀 층마다 공간들이 좀 되게
일반적인 저의 그런 건물이 아니라
층마다 아니면 호실마다 조금
다른 느낌의
뭔가 내부 모습이지 않을까네 이렇게
예상을 합니다 일단은 예전 모습을
보면은
이거였어요 이거
야 이거 진짜
엄청 오래된 주택이었습니다 저 예전에
살던 집 같은 저희 집 예전에
이랬거든요 세필지
총네 필지네 필지를 하필했습니다
지금요 상태 건물을 전매도인 전
매도인이 매입을 했습니다 그래서
2010년도에 한 64억 정도의
매입을 했어요 그 다음에 착공을
2012년 12월 달에 준공은
14년도 초에 했습니다 그래서 1년
좀 넘게 걸렸어요 그리고 지하 2층에
지상 5층 건물이고 대지는 무려
149평입니다 149평에
연면적이
445평 그래서 건물이 꽤 크죠
사이즈가 전 매도인이 되게 좀 유명한
회사였는데
암튼
기업이었습니다
기업이 가지고 있다가 건물을 이제
신축한 다음에 매각한 사례라고 보시면
될 것 같고 지금 옆에 건물도 비슷한
느낌으로 지어놨어요 그래서
똑같은 곳에서 지어 놓은 걸로 알고
있는데 그래서 요것도 이제
지어놓고 매각을 했습니다 그래서
보면은
2021년도에 개인 명의로 매입을
했습니다
2021년도에 195억에
매입을 한 것으로 좀 보여지고요
그리고 대출은
채권 최고 얘기한 96억 정도 되니까
실 채무에 관한 80억 정도 될
것으로 좀 예상이 됩니다 195억에
4.6% 하면은
취득세가 한 9억 정도 돼요
9억 정도 뭐 대략 한 10억 정도
된다라고 치면은
총 들어간게 한
205억 정도 그 다음에 여기에
80억
빼면은
현금이 125억이
들어갔습니다
근데 여기 이제 근저당권 또 빼면 한
124억
그래도
현금이 한 120억 정도 들어갔습니다
그래도 건폐율 한 50%에 용적률 한
208%
근데 원래 3종에서 250% 까지인데
아마 좀 건축하면서 사선이라든지 뭐
기타 좀 제한 상황들이 좀 있어서요
정도로 지어 놓은 거 같습니다
지하 2층에 지상 5층이고 다 이제
근린생활시설로 되어 있고요
지구단위계획 구역되어 있고 그 다음
지하 2층이 이제 기계식 주차장이고
기계식 주차는 17대 그 다음에
자주식으로 한대 그리고 이거를
간삼에서 했어요 간삼 건축사사무소
여기가
굉장히 큰 건축사 사무소거든요
엄청 유명한 데서 설계를 했습니다
시공도 대림에서 했구요 그래서 좀
설계가 좀 특이하게 너무 잘 된 거
같아요 그래서 내부가
[음악]
궁금하긴 한데
임차인들도 되게 맛집이 많아요 지금
한식집은 미쉐린 가이드 내부
인테리어도 되게 잘 했네요
여기도 약간 여기가 이제 지하 같은데
지하인데 약간 이렇게 썬크는
햇빛이 되게 잘 들어오네요
맛있겠는데요
양식집도 있고
피부과도 있고
있을게 다 있네요 내부가 되게 잘
되어 있어요 바로 한남더힐 앞입니다
그 다 이제 여기 오면 발렛으로
주차를 하거든요
피부과도 있어요 제가 알고 있기로는
월세가 한 5천 넘게 나와요
완성된 건물이라고 보시면 될 것 같고
그리고 임차인도 뭐 그때 매각
당시에도 뭐 공실이 없었어요
임대료도 상당히 좀 잘 나오는
건물이어서 수익용으로
매입한 것으로 좀 보여집니다 그리고
건물도 너무 이쁘게 잘 돼 있어서
여기 예전에 그 한효주 씨도 건물
가지고 있었거든요 한효주 씨도 가지고
있다가
매각을 한 것으로 알고 있습니다
요거 건물이었고 여기도 좀 사람들
많이 찾긴 해요 한남동이 앞에도
실제로 거래금액도 좀 되게 높게 되고
있고 그래서 한남동 중에서는
그래도 되게 좀 좋은 위치에
매입한 것으로 좀 보여지고
완성되어 있는 건물을 매입했다 그리고
195억 기준으로 했을 때 수익률이
한 그래도 3% 정도 나오거든요 보통
이제 여배우 분들이 이렇게 좀 깔끔한
건물 많이 또 투자하시거든요 완성되어
있는 거
송혜교 님도 좀 이런 식으로 좀 관리
편하고 수익 발생되고 아니면 내가
자주 가는 자주 가시기도 할 것
같아요 여기 워낙 되게 유명한
음식점 뭐 이런 것도 많아서 또 자주
가는 그렇게 좀 부자들이 많이 사는
그런 곳에
빌딩을 투자한 것으로 좀 보여집니다
이쪽 지역도 여러분들이 한번 가서이
분위기라든지 이런 것들도 한번 좀
보시면 좋을 것 같아요 좀 이렇게
고급스러운 분위기가 있긴 하거든요 그
다음에 건물 내부도 좀 되게 궁금한데
한번 다음에 한번 가봐야겠네요 그래서
좀 다른 건물들보다는 되게 설계에
신경을 많이 쓴 그리고 공사도 또 큰
기업에서 했거든요 그래서 건물도 좀
되게 잘
지어져 있지 않았을까 뭐 이렇게
예상을 합니다 오늘 영상 여기까지
하겠습니다 감사합니다